on youtube there are several creators
with either a big four background
or an mbb background talking about their
experiences but very rarely you really
can see a conversation
where these two perspectives meet and
you can really understand and discuss
what the differences are
between big four companies and mbb
companies
this is exactly what this video is going
to be all about
i partnered with kpi consulted at a big
four company and we both
answered the same questions about our
experiences in coinciding and i trust
that the comparison of these answers
will really help you to understand what
distinguishes
mbb firms from big4 firms welcome
everybody to another coffee break
here on my channel firm learning my name
is heinrich and on my channel i want to
help you
to be successful in the first years of
your career
in this video i'm partnering with kp
from the management consultant channel
i can highly recommend her channel she
has some super
interesting videos on consigting and i
will leave a link to her channel
in the video description so check it out
but now instead of me talking about kp
let's hear from her
thanks henry my name is karjal i am a
strategy and innovation consultant at
deloitte i help my clients to create new
products and services
and i also do have a youtube channel on
consulting helping you get into
consulting
wants to in how do you stand out and
also talking through some of the biases
that we really do face
in consulting really excited for this
video and hopefully can help you
understand if
mbb or big4 is for you and indeed this
video is one of two parts so if you want
to see the second part as well
with other questions from both of our
perspective being answered check out
kp's channel in the video description to
see more but now without further ado
let's jump into the questions
big4 is made up of deloitte kpmg ey
and pwc and in 2019 they made up over 40
percent of consulting revenue worldwide
typically they're much larger than mbb
they're more global than mvp
but they also offer more services than
an mbb over the past few years
their consulting divisions have really
branched out to buy smaller agencies
to do supply chain consulting innovation
consulting proposition design
brand and marketing and so on the other
major difference is that mpb definitely
do charge their clients a little bit
more money
and that means you're typically going to
get a higher salary mbb
versus the big four mbb refers to the
leading
three strategy consulting firms mckinsey
bcg
and bain and strategy consulting firms
is a bit misleading because
these firms do not only do strategy
but probably the more correct term to
call them would be
top management consulting the vast
majority of their business is working
together with the top management of
large clients and trying to help them
solve the problems and
issues at the top of mind of the senior
leaders of the top management of these
companies
most of these companies do not
officially disclose their revenue
figures but as per the wikipedia page
the latest estimate is that mckinsey
does roughly 10 billion dollars in
revenue
bcg sits at around 8 billion and bain
sits
around 5 billion regarding employees
mckinsey and bcg are more or less on a
similar level at around 20
000 whereas bain sits at about 10 000
employees globally my perspective of
course will be biased by my time
at mckinsey and of course there are also
differences among these three firms but
overall also from talking to friends who
worked at these other companies at bcg
or bain
i do believe that they are quite similar
in many ways which is why you can
consider my
answers indicatively right for these
other firms as a way
for me personally it wasn't a big factor
i did my
undergrad in munich at the university of
munich and this is when i applied to
mckinsey for an internship and while
being a good and renowned university for
business in germany
it's a large public university with
thousands of
students attending the business program
every semester but overall yes it is
true that mckinsey likes to hire from
the so called target schools from these
elite universities i met
lots and lots of people at mckinsey who
started at the new
as ivy league or at oxbridge or at the
lse or at any other of these
very renowned universities so for sure
this
will increase your chances of getting
into mbb
and adding to that there might also be
differences in the offices how this is
perceived for instance in the us
the differences among universities are
much more salient
compared to a country like germany so
you can likely expect that
in the u.s the target schools are more
important more relevant than what they
are in germany so overall yes it will
help you but by no means this is a hard
requirement and you can get successfully
into mbb without studying at a target
square
so i studied at imperial college london
and definitely the people who
joined with me they definitely came from
a variety of different universities
honestly in the past
big4 definitely did use to recruit from
these elite schools that henry's
mentioned like oxbridge
ivy league and imperial but diversity is
a big thing for big4 firms today
and they hire from a variety of
universities what they've realized is
that hiring from these universities
brings different viewpoints to the table
for their clients everyone has different
experiences different challenges and
struggles in life
and they can go to a variety of
different universities having a good uni
can definitely help you get screened
okay
but it isn't everything so they look at
education
experiences extracurricular activities
achievements and skills
for anyone thinking that education plays
a massive part in the recruitment
process
i would say go on to linkedin have a
look at where people
have studied at mbb and big4 and you'll
realize that education isn't the end all
yes up or out exists and the underlying
idea is that over time
either you continue advancing to the
next role or at some point if you
fail to advance you will be asked to
leave the firm
though it is not as brutal as it maybe
sounds and the reason is that there's a
very transparent
feedback process at every point in time
you
know where you stand in the process and
in the evaluation if for
any reason your performance will be
started to seen as problematic
there will be many iterations of
feedback that people will give you
people will actively reach out to you to
work together with you to work on your
weak points
to make sure that you meet the bar that
you meet
the requirements for the next level to
really help you as much as possible to
be
successful in the firm that being said
at every level there will be people who
will be asked to leave the firm
if you start at an mbb company you just
need to be aware
that these are the roots of the game
that this is how it works
this being said if this is something
that happens to you
the hr professionals will work together
with you to find you a new job
of course mbb firms have a vast network
and will work together with you to help
you
identify new job opportunities that suit
your needs
yes in many countries big4 definitely
does have an up and out process
but in the uk it's actually very
difficult to get fired
for poor performance we have this asus
code of practice
by law it basically says that you have
to consistently show you're a bad
performer for a firm to fire you
they also need to support you so they
need to give you a few chances and also
put you on a supporting plan
to show that they've tried to improve
your performance so the big four does
have very transparent feedback processes
happens once every quarter where
leadership get together to speak about
you
to understand who you support and
identify how everyone's doing
that means it's also a very structured
promotion process so once every year in
the junior levels you can go for
promotion
even early promotion and you have a
defined set of guidelines that you need
to meet
every grade for you to get promoted so
it's really clear if you want to go for
promotion
you know exactly what you need to do
regarding the project setup what
probably distinguishes
most mbb projects from big4 projects
is the team size and the type of topics
that the consultants will work on it is
no
secret that mbb fees are rather
expensive
and for sure more expensive than your
average big4 firm for these
reasons mbb teams are rather small and
rather work on the most important most
pressing challenges that the company is
facing
a typical mbb team size ranges from two
to four consultants
including the project lead and then one
or two partners
joining the team once or twice a week
and then adding their value in their
perspective this way
this means that from early on you are
one of two
one of three or one of four consultants
and of course by that
you are significant part of the team the
responsibility that you will get early
on from your very first
project will be significant due to the
importance of the topics that mbb
firms work with you will work together
with rather senior executives
often even with board members and will
learn to develop
documents for this audience and present
in front of them as well
this being said mbb firms in the last
years
tried to expand the diversity of their
projects in other directions as well
which is why today you can
find projects in an mbb firm that now
more closely resemble
projects that you would also find in
big4 specifically most mbb
firms today also have different
variations of implementation
type of consulting services this means
that you do not only work
on super strategic super conceptual
projects but you also might find
yourself in a position to really work on
projects that are much closer to an
implementation setting that are really
about
execution and bringing ideas to life
often ideas and then
prior teams before you develop with a
client so from this perspective there
for sure
is an overlap regarding the types of
projects and the team setup
between mbb and big4 though still the
typical mbb project will be different
than the typical big4 project
just like henry's mentioned mbb have
definitely branched out to do
implementation work
but big4 definitely real king when it
comes to breadth of services
we acquire some really cool companies to
strengthen our practices from strategy
technology operations supply chain human
capital as well as brand marketing and
innovation
if you're working on a strategy or brand
project you typically do work in smaller
teams of two to four
you'll end up having a partner who looks
after the relationship with the client
a manager and maybe an analyst or a
consultant on that team
on operations and technology projects
they can be really small
from two to four but they can be massive
to 300
so you need to have a variety of
leadership on there
and work in smaller structures where are
still ensuring there's a big
team so typically they end up being in
work streams and you have smaller teams
within it
but those small teams end up being from
4 to 15 to even 20 sometimes
thank you for watching i really hope
that you took some value out of this
video
if you have any more questions just
leave me a comment below in the comment
section
and i will do my very best to answer
every single one please if you took any
value out of this video please destroy
the like button for the youtube
algorithm and also
subscribe to my channel to see even more
content like this if you want to see
even more from me
hit me up on my instagram my instagram
handle is firm learning
and i also have a mailing list with even
more content you can find a sign up link
to
that in the video description thank you
for watching i really appreciate your
time
i wish you the very best have a good
evening all the best to you and see you
next saturday